so when I get this title I actually
wasn't sure what I was going to talk
about so I gave some cryptic title and
this is actually what it means I want to
talk to do two things
and this is sort of echoing on some of
the things that have been said already
this week which is that if you try to
make something parallel maybe you can
try to approximate it and it's gonna
help you do that better in some way so
the first thing I'm going to talk about
is greedy asset cover
you know that that's kind of has a
linear dependency and somehow we're
gonna approximate it to break the linear
dependency the other thing is on sort of
along the lines of the talk that Ali
gave a couple days ago and that's using
ideas from streaming algorithms to make
to solve problem in parallel let me say
a little bit of other context I'm
actually thinking about creating fast
parallel algorithms for shared memory
machines so these are the kind of
machines we're talking about right now
and in reality these machines are kind
of messy to think about so for the
purpose of this talk we're gonna be
focusing on simple metrics like work and
depth and also throw in there a cache
cost I was just briefly mentioned what's
really going there now as we have seen
already we want work to be as small as
we can basically linear or something
while you log in as for depth you also
want nothing to be small cache cost you
want that to be small - okay let's dive
into that cover how many people in this
room have not seen side cover before all
right good
um just to recap I'm gonna talk I'm
gonna be talking about the most basic
version and we're just at topper so this
is an instance of the set cover problem
you get elements and you get sets you
know that if you take all the sets it's
going to cover all the elements and the
task is
surely simple to state it says you want
to cover all the elements using the
fewest number of sets in this case I can
pick three sets then I will cover
everything great applications lots of
things always keep that for now ah okay
there is a very simple algorithm to use
that cover and that's the greedy
algorithm it's us until everything is
copper I'm going to pick on the set that
covers the most new elements on so if
you run that what happens is it's going
to pick something like this that's 1 s 2
s 3 S 4 s 5 s whatever on this is really
simple and you can also show that this
is a natural log in approximation but
the more you can also show that you
can't actually beat it unless something
horrible happens so in in a sense this
is one of the best thing that people can
do assuming that you have a hard
instance and P is not equal to NP this
algorithm is inherently sequential
everything you pick that at an iteration
depends on the choices you made in the
previous ones so if you're thinking
about making this parallel what can you
do first a bad news if you want to
simulate the greedy process exactly it's
gonna be P complete that has been shown
before so a lot of efforts have been put
into approximating it
there have been results of this kind so
in the past either you get like 2 times
natural log an approximation or in both
cases the work is more than the work
that you would do in the supernal case
what I'm gonna be talking about in this
talk is a result that basically says you
can get essentially log an approximation
with a little more and you get linear
work and the depth is poly log so that
gives you plenty of parallelism
the cash cost is not more expensive than
doing sort on em okay so here's how
we're gonna do it the first idea is
actually simple and very natural
geometric budgeting we said previously
the original algorithm is going to pick
the best set that covers the most new
elements we're not going to do that
anymore we're gonna sort of being things
on a geometric scale so per iteration
we're going to identify all sets that
cover at least say 99% of the best set
and then we're going to bulk process
them in a way that hopefully mimics the
greedy behavior so now kind of
immediately from here you can see that
if the best set covers tinu elements the
weekend urges choose the set of stoppers
or say 1 minus epsilon times da that T
if you if you pick any of these sets if
you look at any one of them they are
good because you chose them from the
sets that are almost as good as the best
one but the problem here is that if you
take them together there might be a lot
of sharing so you can't really take
everything that you pick up there
because that could lead to something bad
so the idea the next idea is you
actually want to decide what to do so
we're going to come up with the process
which looks pretty much like maximal
independence that but it is not really
independent
it is nearly independent what it does is
so you have a bucket of good sets
remember these are things that are like
say 0.99 of the best these are the sets
and you want to sort of decide whether
to accept these things make it part of
your set cover or you want to reject it
so that's what we do the property of the
things that we reject or that add the
shoe thing all the things that we accept
each of the reject one has say 99% of
its original coverage remaining
and then for the other side for e 20
accepts on we want to show that it
covers at least a 98 percent of the
unique elements of the original coverage
99 98 a really Harvey Drury it's just a
placeholder for a one minus Epsilon okay
so suppose you have this routine here's
what you can do first
look at those step size and then you're
gonna bend them according to their sizes
so you can go send them to the buckets
correspond to the sizes okay now I'm
gonna go through the largest one here's
what I'm gonna do when man is on it the
things that managed us I'm going to
accept I'll put that to the settle
resolution the things that man man is
rejects go through annex pocket okay so
you keep doing this you keep doing this
there can be at most log and buckets
right okay so assuming that we can show
that madness can be computed in linear
work and some Polliwog depths where
that's the linear in the some of the set
sizes that you feed to madness what we
can do is initial bucketing is just well
linear work you distribute things over
to welcome pockets as you go through
their buckets because man is a linear
work and every time the set goes from
one bucket to the next one the size of
it has to be has to go down at least one
percent you get sort of a geometric sum
so the total work is linear sum of the
sizes so that's it ah before I showed
you how man is actually work let me
actually tell you that this is actually
pretty good in practice so we ran some
experiments on some of these data sets
the biggest data set has about 1.4
billion elements and about 500 million
sets okay we are comparing three things
standard greedy is the greedy algorithm
we all know
love DFG is something called a disk
friendly greedy algorithm on this was
presented in 2010 on sort of a memory
efficient and cache efficient algorithm
which was pretty fast and then there is
parallel madness which is what we are
talking about in this talk first you can
see that there is no loss in solution
quality well all three kind of perform
rough we have to say give the same
quality answers our solution has small
overhead at most 1.8 X I don't know it
was small at least modest and then it
gives you a pretty good speed up so on a
40 core machine you can get between nine
and twenty three point four X verses
itself and it is at least well it is up
to almost 14 times faster than the
previous fastest greedy implementation
okay I'm going to spare you the proof
but here is a way to implement the
linear work madness this is an instance
of the what's that copper you see you
have a bunch of sets and elements right
okay the first step is each set is going
to pick a random value between 0 and 1
so let's say you've got these numbers in
the second step each element is going to
look around it and look at all the sets
that it belongs to it is going to
extract out the maximum value there you
can see so each element has max of
everything you can see so you can sort
of shape them according to the value did
that it takes and this is what you get
okay so in the third step you're going
to accept things you can accept a set if
at least 98% of that set has the same
value as the value that that set gets ok
so these guys are accepted the green one
becomes empty and now we are going to
reject things if the remaining
is less than 99% of what it was before
so the green thing now is empty we're
gonna reject it so let's burn that it's
gone and you're gonna repeat until the
whole process removes all the steps so
that decides sets into the buckets that
we accept and buckets that we reject and
that gives us order in work this is a
depth for madness okay let me switch
gear and talk about something kind of
completely different and that's doing
triangle counting in a streaming graph
the problem is very simple you want to
approximate the number of triangles in a
streaming graph okay I'm gonna make some
assumptions and this is sort of a common
assumption in this business which is you
have lots of triangles in that graph and
also for this talk we're gonna say that
the graph is simple no parallel edges
you know loo nothing like that
a streaming graph the motto we're
working with is basically a sequence of
edges are just flying by you so you get
to observe these edges flying by you and
the broad go here is you want to
maintain some property of this graph
without actually remembering the whole
graph and this is well motivated because
we have lots of evolving data like
Twitter like Facebook and phone calls
and there's been a lot of prior work
actually a lot of them are done by
people in this room both in the
streaming grav literature and in the
static graph literature also both in a
sequential and parallel setting so what
we're trying to do here is we want to
accurately approximate a number of
triangle in a streaming graph on sort of
a small as machine on to those here be
compact and be fast here's a result in
terms of space and time I'm going to
talk about the sequential complexity
first
then talk about parallel later M here is
the number of edges gamma is some
parameter we defined I'm not going to
bother with this definition it is talk
but it is bounded by the max degree and
it tends to be much smaller in social
graphs because of the power law nature
and tau is the number of triangles for
this talk thing of gamma as being the
same as the max degree in the graph and
and the time to process M edges is
firstly in M + essentially the space
bound and this is assuming some kind of
bulk processing which we are going to
talk about later on okay so let me go
into the first part which is how to
design a compact data structure to do
this here is one pretty common recipe in
designing streaming algorithms
especially if the things that you just
want to get an estimate out of it first
step you're going to design an estimator
that has the right expectation okay so
in this case you want to design a random
variable T such that the expected value
of T is a number of triangles it might
have a high variance so you're going to
run multiple copies of this random
variable and then combine them in some
way let's say I take meeting of means to
improve the certainty if you use median
it means you can see that roughly you
need variance of T over tau squared
estimators to get on the desired
accuracy and and actually um if you want
accuracy one minus Epsilon the
dependence is epsilon 1 over epsilon
squared okay so the name of the game
here at least if you follow the recipe
is to design something which has small
variants do you understand this idea
u.s. drama in solution is this not real
what we are gonna do but okay let's say
here's one way to be on the estimator
you pick three unique vertices randomly
and then as the edges arrived your
constructive a B and C a perform a
triangle this is not a smart way of
doing it but you can see that the
probability that ABC is a triangle is
the number of triangles over in choose
three okay so in expectation Y of T is
like that no more triangles so this
gives you the right expectation but the
problem is in the variance if you run
how many copies you need to do this the
variance turns out to be roughly
something like n cubed times the number
triangles so recording to bounce we have
seen before
we need roughly and cubed over tau
estimators this is a lot of estimators
so you want something better and that
comes in to reducing the variance so we
have a way a pretty natural way of doing
a sampling um and here's jos the first
step you pick a random edge r1 and we
gonna call that out one so let's say
this isn't my random Patrick Joe's been
your Andy ah okay these are the
neighbors these are things that are
incident on on that edge we can account
the number of edges incident on the
first edge that we picked that come
after it right away this is a view that
sort of if you have everything up front
you're gonna do it but then we're gonna
talk about how to make it screaming
later on okay so in this case you can
count and let's say these three things
come if after r1 and the topmost guy
can't before it so we're gonna say three
now we're gonna pick a random at r2
incident on our one that comes after the
first edge we picked so among these
three choices we're gonna pick one of
them uniformly at random so let's say I
pick that guy okay
and then finally I'm gonna I'm gonna
test whether that at the edge from by r1
and r2 is ever closed by an edge that
comes later on so basically testing
whether the purple edge exists in this
dream okay let me name things the number
of edges said that is an aura one can
gather it let me call that C I'm gonna
call the last edge
the purple one are three claim for any
triangle T in the stream the probability
that that these three edges coincide
with this triangle is exactly one over m
times C so you can think of this as a
process of sampling wedges except it's
not uniform is actually by us and this
is how much is bias by so you can
construct an estimator by I'm biasing it
and to do that you just define T to be M
times C of are 1 and 0 when now one is
not found is easy to show that
expectation of this random variable is
tau and also we can show that the
variance of it is something like M times
gamma times tau so in a sense it needs m
times gamma over tau estimators so what
is so far is assuming you have the whole
graph up front but in a streaming
setting you don't so here's here's how
we're gonna do it the goal here is for
each estimator you just you want to
maintain just these quantities R 1 R 2 3
and the count well and also global what
you want to maintain how many edges you
have seen already through our one um is
pretty easy to maintain using say
reservoir sampling from years ago
decades ago actually and the idea if you
have not seen it before is let's say our
one is the current random
so you know by definition that the
probability that that thing is
Summit's is 1 over m so when you see a
new edge you know that the determinant
total number of edges is M plus 1 so
you're gonna use a simple rule it's us
basically it replace our 1 with the new
edge with probability of 1 over n plus 1
otherwise you keep the old one so this
is easy conceptually you can also
maintain or two the same way tweeting
condition on our 1 these are just like
sub streams of the thing but that's kind
of bad right because if you do that in
this implementation then every time it
adds arise you're gonna have to send
that out to all the estimators to see if
that is incident on r1 and to do the
sampling so that will result is
something like M times the space bound
ignoring epsilon and Delta terms so we
looked into designing a faster algorithm
and the idea here is to bulk process
edges let's say that about on that a
batch of W edges arrive at a time and
this is sort of motivated by the fact
that maybe you don't need to query it
every single time instant so you can
sort of buffer everything and then
process them together and you can create
a data structure to track those states
of all the estimators simultaneously and
if you can do this and say linear time
linear in W then if you set W to be like
the number of estimators the cost per
ads become something like constant and
you get the total time of what I claim
let me sketch how you would take level 2
edges from this in this setting so let's
say this is the batch of edges that you
have you got these are things that
arrive together or you pretend that they
arrive together okay you're gonna first
number them so that you know which order
they come in
so I'm gonna number them one two or
three up to seven there are seven of
them and I'm gonna sort of bucket them
and then I'm gonna collect basically
doing a sort of some sort
okay so these are by the end points so
we got things incident on a B C D and F
there's no whiskey and you can order
them in increasing level number so so
let's say I want to know how many edges
arrive after C F I can just go to C and
then and then look at it and then I know
that there are two edges coming out
after that this process R can be done
pretty easily in parallel using say
primitives such as sword and scan and it
takes at most sort of W plus sort of our
time W is the size of the batch and R is
the number of estimators you're
maintaining and it has poly lock depth
so I'll do a quick summary of some
experiments that we did okay so on a
reasonably large grouts we tried it up
to about five billion edges we we get a
rate of about 8 million edges per second
using a machine with 12 cores and the
error rate is less than 5% using about 2
million estimators the bound I said was
actually a very conservative so when you
actually looked at the the actual
estimate it's it's way better but the
running time is pretty on the bound is
Bridget presides on the way we parallel
wise it is has pretty little overhead
let's say less than 1.5 X and you get
pretty good speed up so on a 12 core
machine you get more than 10x
consistently of course on reasonably big
graphs if you were using it on and say a
million edges maybe you know
on the same sampling algorithms can be
extended to do sampling so you can
sample triangles from this dream it also
extends to larger clicks of course at
the cost of more space we also have
extension to considering the sliding
window scenario where you you just want
your you're just interested in the last
25 million edges okay so let me
summarize so we looked at essentially
two results
one is that 3d set topper despite being
looking sequential you can actually make
it parallel by doing approximation on
the process itself and you lose some
accuracy but then you can go way faster
than before in the case of triangle
counting again batching and an
approximation help speed it up and help
you paralyze it so now I have two open
questions actually there are lots of
open questions that I'm listening to
over here so set cover has a natural
generalization to say sub mashallah
cover or that sort of things can we get
a poly log depth algorithm that was all
set modulo a copper subject you may be
may try constrains or whatever and for
triangle counting so even though the
techniques here allow the lesion of of
the edges I'm sorry allow sliding window
it doesn't actually allow for things
like let's say let's say in the stream
there is an event that says this edge is
gone so we cannot explicitly delete
edges can we get this kind of edge
deletion in the same space pal I realize
that there are sketches that allow you
to delete edges but then the space
complexity is a bit more
thank you what's that I have thought a
bit about a sub martial law covered on
what happens there is so in this in the
case of cetera you help leverage on both
the sets and the elements you can argue
about sort of a bipartite graph and the
structure on the bipartite graph in the
sub modulo case it's not clear what we
lose at leverage I mean I don't know
what's going down so I can't say log end
rounds or something like that there were
there was another question
so I have two answers for that first if
you think about theoretical results on
the two bounds that are not really
comparable because that's the sort of
the additive error and this is relative
error in practice I haven't actually
tried his algorithm but I think that he
is more specificially if you wanted to
same accuracy I mean the kdd paper I
don't know is it because it's right yeah
so in practice we don't have any actual
comparison but my sense is that the
despite the theoretical down being in
comparable that paper will be more space
efficient if you just want the same
practical guarantee
any order that that's why we have to
track the number of edges that are
incident on the first edge